here's the game imagine you were taking
care of yourself like someone you cared
for so imagine someone you care for and
pretend that's you maybe it's a son or a
daughter or a friend
now imagine five years down the road
you can have what you want need you can
be who you are but you have to figure
out what it is what is it what do you
want what do you need
and and don't worry about getting it
right just get it down for 15 minutes
that's a good start the whole exercise
you can do in about 90 minutes but we
had
students do that say before they went to
University
and just doing it for 90 minutes
developing that Vision drop their
dropout rate 90 or 50 percent 50 percent
and increase the grade point average 35
percent
and that just shows you how badly it had
been done before because
students went to University with no
vision they have no idea what they were
doing there and so of course they didn't
half of them didn't succeed because they
had no idea why they were doing anything